when hotel security video surfaced last
month showing Kansas City Chiefs running
back cream hunt in a physical fight with
a woman it reminded many people of
another incident involving an NFL player
nearly five years ago you may remember
in February 2014 Baltimore Ravens
running back Ray Rice was seen dragging
his unconscious fiance out of an
elevator a second video revealed later
showed that Rice had punched her and
knocked her out in the elevator his team
dropped him in he has not played
professional football since ricin his
fiancee her name is janae married just
weeks after the incident and they now
have two children in an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning we spoke to
Ray and Jenna Rice at their Connecticut
home last week we learned how they're
making their marriage work and why they
stayed together and how the creme Hunt
video has affected their lives so I'm
wondering what you thought when you
first saw the creme hunt tape well
obviously you know you look back and you
see their similarities
I knew that our name was gonna get
brought up in the conversation I do
think people certainly see you as a
poster boy for domestic violence caught
in a very graphic way on tape and how do
you feel about that early on you can
feel like a lot of keep bringing my name
up you can make excuses or you can
actually do the hard work I've heard you
say that there are many underlying
things and as you've had time to reflect
and really do a deep dive for both of
you yes what was the answer you came up
for yourself about the underlying issues
one of the underlying issues for me was
I never wanted to ask my help
football for me was my counseling it was
my therapy it was my psychologist it was
everything did you see domestic abuse in
your own home when you were growing up
it was more of my mom going through you
know a bad relationship that's when I
started to realize I was normalizing
abnormal things I was a man at 11 and
then at 21 I got drafted and became a
boy and that was a revelation to you
about about there are many different
kinds of abuse is that what you're
saying to us that's how to process that
yes we didn't have a physical abuse
problem but I can say there were
different forms of abuse that take that
took place was it
no financial you get to the physical and
that's obviously like if it's one time
is still one time too many I'm curious
janae did you think that you were in
abusive relationship knowing what he
just said that there are many different
forms of abuse no no I just thought we
were being a typical you know boyfriend
and girlfriend like we argue and argue
and I didn't really sit back and think
about it until I was forced to think
about it janay rice has never seen the
video from inside the elevator the one
where ray punches her I think it's so
hard for people to understand right why
you haven't looked at that tape I was
there yeah I lived it I don't really
need to relive it over and over again
just to appease the world you've also
said that was the first and only time
yes because you know why you have to
reassure people and the doubting
Thomases and I would almost put myself
in that group because it justifies every
statistic in the world about what
happens in an abusive situation right a
that that's the first time and oh by the
way just happened to be caught on tape
it had never happened before and be four
years later that has never happened
right the all the naysayers the people
who doubt our genuineness they could
spend an hour with us and they will walk
away and say okay yeah what do you think
Ray when you look at it now I hate that
person I hate him somewhere down the
line everybody was saying does he
deserve a second chance for football and
distance I know that I actually got my
second chance
how sit right here with your wife
they're my darkest moments and I sacks
myself how can she even want to support
me like but a lot of people wondered
that that's understandable but I think
what's misunderstood about us is that
the friends we were before the incident
that's why like I said when I look at
Kareem's hunt I want to know what his
life was like I want to know what
happened in life you know I know
Kareem has apologized and has expressed
remorse for the survivors of domestic
but you know what guys apologies mean
nothing if people don't feel a you've
done the word I'm going to work and that
you're truly remorseful and that this
isn't just some attempt to get back into
football well see that that one for me
is something that I understand what was
being said earlier that was about you
know is this a ploy to get back in the
football I mean I'd be the first one to
say it I don't have to retire to tell
you I'm done with football the pressure
I was under of being a star that was the
person I hated the most why did you give
this man a second chance I know it's
hard for people to understand it and I'm
not here to force people to understand
it was never a thought whether I was
gonna leave or not because I knew that
that wasn't him in that moment this is
somebody I've known since I was fifteen
years old I knew that we had work to do
and I was willing to move forward and
put in the work you said that you don't
want to play football again ray but do
you think you deserve a second chance
no I didn't deserve another chance how
seriously do you think the NFL is taking
domestic abuse I met with them who you
know they're trying to do the right
thing I know they are working with
groups to try to get more of an
understanding and they're doing the work
in addition to Kareem Hunt the NFL is
also dealing with Rubin foster last
month the San Francisco 49ers released
the linebacker after a domestic violence
arrest just days later the Washington
Redskins signed him though he's
ineligible to play or practice with the
team while the NFL continues to
investigate how can people take that the
NFL is taking abuse against women
seriously I know the NFL they're not
trying to push people who do bad things
though abuse against women they're not
trying to push those guys on the field
have you spoken to Kareem hunt no I have
it do you want to I would love to help
anyone that's willing to go to long haul
well we reached out to the NFL which
confirmed that rice shared his story is
part of the league's domestic violence
education program the NFL says it rice
has an important message to share and
that his commitment is sincere and if
you're a victim of domestic violence and
you need help you can call the national
domestic violence hotline that's one
eight hundred seven nine nine seventy
two thirty three I also thought that his
commitment is very sincere he does a lot
of speaking to NFL players and to
college players he's coaching high
school football at his old high school
he volunteers there but I was really
impressed with janay rice I have to say
she's not a little mouse burger robot
wife because I couldn't understand after
knowing and seeing that video how she
was able to take him back and and she
says that this was the first and only
time I really pressed them on that
because I said that defies everything
that we know about domestic violence in
any type of relationship and they both
insist that was the case well remember
he not only punched her exactly knocked
her unconscious in the first videotape
that we saw was just of Ray Rice
dragging her and I had that interview
with Roger Goodell I remember that at
the time but I am glad just they seem
like they are in a good place and Tre
are getting therapy they need to discuss
this and maybe try and help people learn
something more about domestic violence
whether they were a victim of it
themselves and then repeated that
behavior and how to end it and that's
what they mean about hard work to your
point I mean they've had extensive
counseling they still have counseling
and they credit the counselor and
another thing I think is very telling
her parents have been married for 30
years and her parents support their
relationship and as you pointed out when
people have been giving apologies
recently they have one answer it's very
short and let me get back to the other
thing yeah there's no way you can sit in
that interview and give the answers Ray
Rice did that many answers at that depth
without feeling it and feeling it he did
he run away from it John because I sort
of had a test test judgmental attitude I
have to say but he didn't run away from
any of the questions and they both
embraced anything that we wanted to talk
about hear him say that he just didn't
deserve a second chance at NFL was
something most people don't expect and
doesn't want to play football again
and his second chances she gave him the
second chance and that's what matters
Dan you can hear our full interview with
Ray and Jenna Rice on today's CBS this
morning podcast it's also available on
Apple's podcast app and all major audio
plan
forms